une asbl fait la merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on vient
d'entendre la directrice du fmi faire
des recommandations pour les pays les
plus endettés parmi ces recommandations
se concentrer sur le système de santé et
aider les entreprises et les familles
avec une injection fiscale massive
est ce que c'est c'est tenable pour les
pays les plus endettés
bon effectivement il ya beaucoup de
défis face à des économies comme les
pays du sud notamment sur la question
sanitaire mais beaucoup plus sur la
question économique le fonds monétaire
international parle d'une perte de plus
de 9 milliards
neuf mille milliards de dollars cette
année dans l'économie mondiale oxfam
précise qui aura plus de 500 millions de
pauvres de plus cette année il ya encore
aussi des enjeux à caractère social
comme le nombre de chômeurs ou la
famille dans certains pays africains où
d'autres pays de l'amérique de
l'amérique latine donc sont autant de
défis qui oblige à aux institutions
internationales d'intervenir
surtout pour les pays qui l'endettement
extrêmement élevé vous avez parlé dans
le reportage de l'argentine également le
liban venezuela et d'autres d'autres
pays qui souffre d'une certaine
politique monétaires et financières en
faillite
donc là dessus je crois qu'on est sur un
plan international on passe à un nouveau
paradigme économique qui exige une
certaine une nouvelle génération on va
dire de problématiques économiques pour
les pays de 2,2 sud est donc surtout que
les défis économiques sens extrêmement
important et ça ajoute à ça et aussi des
enjeux sociaux à pommes le défi
démographique comme la question de
guerre la question des géopolitique par
exemple du gazel le changement
climatique sans autant d'affaires qui
sont maintenant extrêmement importante
pour définir une politique économique
pour ce genre de pays alors vous parliez
de l'argentine justement l'argentine ne
peut plus rembourser sa dette et pour
éviter le défaut de paiement
le gouvernement se laisse jusqu'au 22
mai pour trouver un accord avec le fmi
mais quel genre d'accord selon vous on
peut trouver dans ce contexte
je crois d'après les expériences qu'on a
eu depuis longtemps c'était une jour en
fait imposer des plans d'austérité afin
de réduire la dépense publique par par
les gouvernements est également il faut
chercher des dz même si que moi je suis
pas vraiment quelqu'un qui qui
recommande cette quelle politique d aide
soit pour les pays de l'amérique latine
ou même pour les pays de l'afrique parce
que c'était une politique qui a
encouragé à la rente qui a encouragé à
la corruption plutôt qu'à relever
l'économie
je crois que la meilleure façon pour
aider ce genre de pays qui sont en
souffrance financière et économique
c'est de mettre des investissements
c'est d'injecter des investissements il
vend par la suite créer de l'emploi qui
vont améliorer la croissance économique
et de c2c payer ceux qui portent en
quelque sorte un développement inclusif
porteur de progrès et de prospérité pour
ce genre de deux pays
bon bien évidemment là là maintenant
l'austérité tout le monde parle de
l'austérité même les pays qui ont une
certaine richesse et qui sont
caractérisés comme étant des pays du sud
je parle par exemple de l'arabie
saoudite ou de l'algérie d'autres pays
qui ce qui se base sur la rente
pétrolière qui lancent des plans
d'austérité afin de réduire au maximum
la dépense la dépense publique et
attendre en fin de compte un
déconfinement économique totale pour
relancer l'économie
donc là dessus il ya un rôle extrêmement
important qui doit être jouée par les
banques afin de mettre des facilités de
caisse et également des crédits pour les
pour les entreprises et il faut savoir
aussi que dans les périodes de crise ya
également des opportunités je crois que
dans cette période on a vraiment une
l'émergence de ces de ce capitalisme
digitale de cette économie de la
connaissance les nouvelles technologies
d'informations de connaissances l on a
une place prépondérante
actuellement et je crois que
l'investissement dans cette économie
d'avenir peut porter vraiment des
chances d'avoir une bonne économie dans
le futur est également on trouve qu'il
ya une certaine transformation de
certaines industries qui étaient basés
principalement en asie vers d'autres
pays en afrique où même en amérique
latine et je précise par exemple comme
le cas de la production des des masques
récemment pour contrecarrer cette crise
corolla des russes on a vu qu'il ya des
pays africains qui sont vraiment des
pionniers dans cette production de masse
dans ce qu'il fait que la chaîne de
valeur d'économies qu'elle est en train
de changer
il ya une certaine transition économique
et il ya des opportunités pour des pays
afin de devenir des hubs commerciaux ou
même également des pôles de finances par
apa relationnel fait là pour conclure
plus de 300 parlementaires d'une
vingtaine de pays ont appelé aujourd'hui
le fmi et la banque mondiale a annulé la
dette des pays pauvres face aux
conséquences économiques potentielles de
la pandémie due nouveau coronavirus est
ce que c'est la solution selon vous
certainement ça va aider
c'est une des mesures qui peut qui peut
aider même si que je m'en doute que le
fmi fasse va vraiment annuler ses dettes
elle peut vraiment faire un report par
exemple sur sa palette ont annulé une
partie de cette dette parce que quand
même c'est très très élevé il faut
savoir également que les institutions
internationales comme le fmi la banque
mondiale sont pas des institutions
totalement indépendante mais il ya des
gouvernements qui financent ce genre
d'institutions ou donc content il ya un
manque de financement ça peut créer des
problèmes on l'a vu récemment une
déclaration du président américain qui
veut vraiment le plus financé
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
ça bien sûr ça peut créer des problèmes
pour ce genre d'institution je précise
que ce genre de nos institutions sont
des associations qui ont été créés dans
le lancer dans le don le 20e si à
quelques par rapport à des
problématiques qui concernent le siècle
précédent
maintenant on est dans le xxème siècle
on a besoin d'une nouvelle gouvernance
de nouvelles institutions capables
d'abord de comprendre c'était cette
génération de deux problématiques et de
réagir le plus tôt possible avec avec
les avec les pays surtout les pays du
sud pour éviter une catastrophe sur le
plan humain et sur le plan social
merci beaucoup et younes belle fait là
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
frange rappelle que vous êtes consultant
en relations internationales